So the Iliad is the foundation of Greek
civilization which is the greatest
civilization in human history. The most
creative it gave us um Plato, Fidities,
Heroditus,
Iselis, Urides, Sophocles
um Greek civilization is essentially the
foundation for western civilization. So
the question we will look at today is
how's it possible that one epic poem can
give birth to a civilization.
Okay. So um the thing to understand
about galization is that there are two
important concepts. The first is
sorry.
The second is udeimmonia.
So irrit means virtue, excellence or
character. It's something that makes you
special, what you excel at. Okay. And
traditionally um there are two types of
there's war fighting
and there is speech making.
In Greek civilization,
the paragon of the warrior is of course
Achilles
and the paragon of the great orator, the
great speaker is Adysius.
So we are reading the Iliad
right now. Uh and then after we finish
Iliad, we will read the Odyssey. Okay.
So these are the two great characters in
Greek civilization. Achilles the great
warrior and Odysius the g the great
orator.
Okay. Udimmonia means flourishing.
And the idea of udeimmonia is that you
can only be happy. You can only be
yourself when you are achieving your
when you are expressing your
So for example, Achilles um in Eliad he
tells us that before he came to Troy he
was given a prophecy. He could either
die old at home or die young but a hero
on the shores of Troy. And of and he
said, "Well, duh. Of course, I'm going
to die young in Troy because only by
fighting, only by winning glory can I
achieve udimonia." Okay? And that's why
he's so unhappy when he gets in a fight
with Agamenon and he has to set up the
war and he figures out different ways of
getting back into the battle because
without fighting he can't be Achilles.
He is the paragon of the warrior. Okay.
So that's the idea of udimonia. I can
only be happy when I am be my creative
best when my when I'm achieving my true
potential.
Okay. Now for the Greeks, war fighting
and speech making are really the same
thing but through different means. Okay?
So when you fight a war, what you're
trying to do is you're trying to impose
your reality onto the world and make
others believe what you believe, right?
You do that through force. By uh brute
strength, you show that you're superior
and therefore others must obey you. But
speech making is actually trying to
trying to achieve the same thing. Okay.
But through words,
okay? So rather than through force,
through beauty and through truth, you're
trying to create a new reality that
others submit to. And the example of
course is a speech between the speeches
between Odysius and Achilles. Okay.
Odysius
and Achilles.
All right. So remember the context. Um
Achilles gets in front of Egenmenon. He
refuses to fight and the Trojans led by
Hector are destroying the Greeks. So
Agamenon and Adysius and the others
Nester have a war council and they agree
that they'll go and beg Achilles to come
back. Okay. and Adysius and Nester and
others they go to Achilles and they
present an argument to Achilles and AI
Adius gives a very long speech. Now the
question for us is why are the speeches
in the Iliad so goddamn long right
because Adas could simply say hey
Achilles we'll give you a million
dollars. Will you fight for us please?
He can also say hey Achilles we're
losing a war. Stop being an
Come fight for us. Okay, he can make it
very very short.
Why is it so long? Right? And then
Achilles his response can be like no.
Okay, but he also offers a very long
speech
and the answer is they're not trying to
respond to each other. They're trying to
create their own reality. Okay? So when
with his with with a speech, what you're
really trying to do is you're trying to
project a movie onto the world. You're
trying to create a new reality that
others must inhabit.
Okay? That's why speech making is like
war fighting. You're trying to create
your own reality and impose it on
others. Right? So remember what Audius
is doing. He knows that Achilles for him
it's really about face, right? He's lost
face in front of the others and that's
why he won't back down. That's why he
insists on Eggman on apologizing. Okay.
But Adysius also knows that Eggman
himself won't apologize.
>> [snorts]
>> So for Adysius because he is the great
orator
um that is his what he's going to do try
to do is try to create a new reality
that Achilles inhabits
and
um which will convince him to join
Odysius in the war. Okay. So how does he
do that? What he does is he expands the
imagination
of Achilles.
All right. Right? That's why the speech
is so long because he's trying to create
a new emotional reality for Achilles.
Right? Now, Achilles is selfish, right?
So, what does Odysius say to Achilles?
The first thing he says is Achilles, I
want you to imagine this before us is
great feast. We can see this this feast.
Now, I want you to imagine what's the
opposite of this feast. A great desert
where we're all dying. We're all
starving. And that's the war we're
fighting right now against the Trojans.
That's why we need you back. Okay, so
it's a powerful image. And then he uses
imagery to take Achilles to the present
where Hector is this giant, this god
running around killing all Greeks before
him.
Okay? And then he takes Achilles back to
the past and say, "Remember your father
Pelas? Before you came to the war, you
promised him that you would win glory
for him. You promised that you wouldn't
glory for the Greeks. Okay. Then he
takes Achilles to the future, which is
let's imagine what happens when we win
this war. When we win this war, all the
riches of Troy, all the treasures will
belong to you, Achilles. Again, Manon
will give you his daughter for a bride,
and you will be the glory of all of
Greece. You have treasures and
treasures. Think about the present.
Think about the present. Think about the
past. Think about the future. Okay?
Expand your mind, Achilles.
Right? That's what Adysius is doing.
He's trying to expand Achilles
imagination. And once you enter this
world that Adysius has created, then you
will be convinced to join him. Okay? So
that's what speechm is. Speechm is
projecting a movie onto the world that
everyone can obs observe and then absorb
this new reality. Okay, internalize this
new reality,
right? And Achilles
knows this and Achilles refuses to be
beaten, right? So Achilles for his
speech
counters
this with his own reality which is a
very self-absorbed
reality. Okay. Right. So rather than
expanding outwards like this is once
Achilles continues to expand to to
contract inwards. Right. He uses the
word I I I a lot right me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me. This is never uses I or we.
He's always like we. Okay. So Achilles
says, "Hey, I understand that nefar to
you is a god, but when I saw him, he ran
away from me." Right. Oh, Pelus, my dad.
I should go home to see him. So,
goodbye, guys. And like I got on his
daughter for my wife. I spit on her. I
don't want him this crap. Okay. So, it's
like so he contracts in words. Okay. So,
and that's why the speech is too long is
so long because
in speech making it's a war of
realities. It's a war of narratives.
And you create narratives through
speeches. Okay. But not only that, but
there are certain techniques to speeches
because the goal of speeches is not just
to paint a reality, but you want to
paint a reality in which it is
internalized by other others. And
therefore, you must make it memorable.
Okay? So remember in the beginning of
class, I had you do an assignment which
is um write down the speech, right? And
even though you didn't force yourself to
memorize it, you're able to memorize a
lot. Okay? And that shows you the power
of the speech, the question in it is
what makes the speech so powerful. And
the answer is because it's poetry, guys.
Okay? Poetry.
And the elements of poetry of course are
um imagery.
And this is what Odysius does well. This
is what he specializes in. Okay? Drawing
pictures for you to see, okay?
metaphors,
connections, okay? Metaphors is what we
call connections
and connections are things that
help you clarify reality. Okay? And
which shows you connect which shows you
things that you couldn't see before. So
for example, if I say the sky is like
the sea, that doesn't really surprise
you. Okay? If I say the sky is like a
snail, well, that surprises you. And
because it surprises you, you remember
it. Okay, when you remember it, it
reorders the way you see reality. All
right. Uh you also have um diction,
choice of words, syntax.
Okay. And these are things that both
Adysius and Achilles specialize in,
especially um especially Odysius. Okay?
Does that make sense? All right. So
they're trying to
create these narratives
through their speeches and they have
these techniques and guess what the
Greeks their their education system was
very simple. All they had to do was
memorize the Iliad. Okay? Because when
you memorize the Iliad, you learn how to
make a great speech, right? And you
understood that for me to make a great
speech, I need to have impact. I need
people to remember what I say. I need to
imprint myself [clears throat] on
others.
All right? And this becomes this system
becomes the very basis of visualization,
right? Speech making where to have thing
done you have to go in front of people
and make a speech and create a reality
for people to accept. Right? And this
what is what leads to democracy. Okay?
Are we clear? Okay. Now I want to talk
about
um how in fact Homer creates
civilization. Okay.
All right.
So
[snorts]
um Emanuel Kant
Emio K was a German philosopher and he's
primarily concerned with how we
understand reality. Why do we see the
things that we do? What do we think the
thoughts that we have? And he wrote a
very good book called the critique of
pure reason which he outlines this
theory. Okay. So what he tells us is
this. Traditionally we've understo
ourselves we've unders ourselves as
passive observers of reality. Okay. This
thing is before us. We stand before it
and we try to understand it. Okay.
What caught teaches us is that no we are
in fact active participants in reality
and we shape and form the reality before
us. Okay. So um Kant
divides the world into two.
The first world is the world of
objective reality. the things in
themselves
or the nomina.
Okay. And what's the na? They're just
vibrations. Okay. We talked about this,
right? The entire world is sound
vibrations, frequencies. So, we can
actually see these things. So, we what
we do is we filter the world around us
and turn them into things that we can
understand called the phenomena.
which are the things to us. Okay? Things
to us or the things that seem to us. All
right? And we do so through a filter
called time and space.
So time and space do not exist outside
of us. They in exist inside of us in
order for us to understand reality.
Okay. So time what what does time mean?
Time just means sequence,
right? Sequence is just like 1 2 3 4 5.
We put things in sequence, we create
time.
Space is the idea of sensation.
Okay. Sensation is just basically the
five senses, right?
All right. Now, time and space exists
outside of us because everything outside
of us is just pure energy. Okay. But our
minds can't perceive pure energy.
Therefore, we use time and space,
sequence and sensation to understand the
world around us to to order the world
around us.
Okay.
All right.
So, but what this means is that
if we're able to control time and space,
we can control reality unto itself.
Okay? Does that make sense? And what is
this thing that controls time and space?
This thing is called language.
Okay.
Before we we would just eat each
perceive our own time and space with
language.
Okay. We're now able to come to a
collective understanding of reality.
Right? And who creates language? Poets
create language.
And therefore poets for their poetry
create reality onto itself. That's what
this is is trying to do. He's trying to
for his poetry create a new reality for
everyone to live in. A reality in which
people get along. A reality in which
people like Achilles are able to for
forget their hatred against Eggman and
fight for the common good. Okay.
All right. So even though each of us has
our own understanding of reality,
a poet is able to create a language that
is so beautiful that it comes into us
and we internalize the language, we
absorb the language and we together
create a new reality with the language
as the building blocks. Okay? Does that
make sense guys? All right. All right.
So let me explain now how Homer is able
to do this. Okay, let's let's talk about
how Homer is able to do this. Homer,
how's how is a
poet able to create reality? Okay, so a
poet is unique in the world. Poets um
are really are really prophets. Okay. So
if you look at all these great religious
figures of the past including uh Jesus,
including Zoroa, they weren't religious
figures. They were really poets. Okay.
And how and what how they able to work
is they have a divine connection to the
universe.
Okay. What we call
Okay.
So [clears throat]
there are different names for the
universe. Okay. So Hegel
uh the German philosopher used the term
gist.
Gist. Okay.
What is gist? Well guys, it's hard to
translate because it's German. Okay. But
think of it as three English words. And
in fact actually uh guys will give us
three English words. These three words
are ghost, gist, gist and uh geyser.
Okay, geyser is an eruption. Okay, ghost
is the underlying thing and uh the gist,
the essence. Okay. Okay, that's what the
guys is. The guys is all around us. It's
like the ghost. It's always changing.
It's always becoming. It's always
erupting like a a geyser. And it's
really the essence of things. The the
the gist. Okay. All right. Um Carl Young
had the word he uses eclectic
unconscious.
Eclectic unconscious.
Uh Plato will use the realm
of the forms and ideals.
Okay. Christians will say
heaven whatever. Okay. [clears throat]
All right. But the these are the the
universe. All right. And remember how we
said before
um our memories are stored in the
universe. The universe is almost like a
divine psychic internet, right? So every
single memory is stored inside
the universe. And what poets do is
they're able to access this universe.
And as a result, they're able to
summon the memories of the universe.
And they do and when they do that, they
create epics of poetry. Okay.
All right. The Iliad. [clears throat]
Now, as I keep on discussing when we
read the Iliad, each character is a real
person.
Okay. Each character has a living past,
present, and future. By reading the
speech of Petropolis, you understand his
memories. You understand where he came
from, what he wants, and where he's
going. Okay? So, everyone in the lab is
a living, breathing character. And how's
Homer able to do that? He's able to do
that because a he's able to summon these
people from the universe. Okay? Even
though you're dead, your consciousness
is still alive in the universe.
Even though Homer is no longer with us,
his consciousness is still within the
universe. So, it's possible through
intense meditation to actually connect
with Homer, Dante, Shakespeare, whoever.
Okay? They're all there. And that's what
Homer is doing. He's able to connect
with these people and bring them into
the Iliad. Okay?
But because these people are living
the Iliad itself is a living memory.
Okay. What I mean by that is okay
the purpose of the Iliad is to create a
memory a living memory for people to
observe.
Okay. So remember Homer, he is a bard at
this time. People don't read and write.
So what he's doing is he's doing what
this is is doing, which is he's going
from town to town. People are
surrounding him. He's there's 100 people
and then for the entire evening he
recites his poetry and he's doing what
Adysius is doing. He's painting a movie
for everyone to obs observe together.
And it's the same thing when you go to a
movie theater where yes it's the same
movie but everyone's experience is going
to be different. Okay. And how it
becomes different is that you implant
your own consciousness your own
understanding into the Iliad. So it
becomes a shared creation. And when you
do that, what happens is that this is
really important guys, you connect
directly to the universe.
Okay? So in other words, the Iliad was
created because of inspiration from the
universe, but it's also a portal into
the universe itself.
And this is what allows for new
creations. Okay.
[clears throat]
Okay.
So as you are observing the Iliad
because your own experience is different
because your own connection to the
universe is unique
by interpreting the Iliad you create a
new universe onto itself.
Okay. And this what we call together a
process we call civilization.
All right. This this is what happened.
This is why one poem, the Iliad, was
able to give birth to an entire
civilization because it was so alive, so
powerful, so connected to the universe
itself, to the monad that when you
observed it, you created your into
yourself a portal into the monad, the
universe, the heavens that allow you to
create your own universe that then
connected back to the monad.
Okay.
So, it's just one
dialogue,
right? Any questions? Are are you guys
clear about this?
All right. And think about this. All
right. This is what the Greeks did. And
how do we know it's true? Because even
today, the Ilia speaks to us, right?
The Iliad when we read it, we can
identify with Odysius. We can understand
Achilles. We can we can relate Achilles
to ourselves. We can predict how
Achilles will behave. Okay? And that's
proof that this uh
Iliad
is eternal and immortal because it
connects us to the monad. But knowing
that, this is most important is that you
may not know this, but when the more you
read the Iliad, the more it's opening
your mind. Okay? Your mind is is an
antenna. Okay? Your mind is is an
antenna to the universe, right? So when
you read the Iliad, it's as though your
download speed is now increasing.
You have a faster connection, strong
connection now to the internet. And so
they're able to absorb more. Okay? When
you're able to absorb more, you're able
to create new realities in which you're
able to observe,
which you're able to analyze deeper. All
right? And that's why we read the great
books because it is literally
it allows us connect and talk to God
itself.
Okay. Does that make sense guys? Right.
So
um yeah,
any questions before I move on?
All right. Okay. So what I'm going to do
now is we're going to read together
sorry uh we're not going to read
together an essay by Porche Shali it's
called a defense of poetry and he
explains how this happens. Okay. All
right. So now giving you the theory um
we we'll we'll see how Percy Shelly was
a very famous British Romanic poet how
he how he explains this. Okay.
Okay. Sorry.
[clears throat]
All right. So this is from his essay the
defense of poetry. Okay, it's a very
long essay but but I'll just highlight
for you certain aspects. Okay, so he's
talking about how Homer created
Greekization and um Homer was a B poet
but had a heavy influence on the
playwrights. Okay. The play the three
big players of course are sophocles and
ubides [snorts] and the theater will
become the very essence of Athenian
life. Okay. So what you do what you did
for fun was you would go to a theater
but the theater was more than just
entertainment. It was about education.
It was about enlightenment and vacation.
Okay. So um he talks about the theater
in Athens. Okay. The drama in Athens or
or who
wheresever else it may have approached
to its perfection ever cos coincides
with the moral intellectual greatness of
the age. All right. So the theater at
Athens provoked these tremendous
feelings in people that made them into
moral people with ambition with
creativity. All right. The tragedies of
Athenian poets are as mirrors in which a
spectator beholds himself under a thin
disguise of circumstance of all but that
ideal perfection energy which everyone
feels to be the internal type of all
that he loves, admires and would become.
All right. Okay. So again the idea of
poetry, the idea of truth is that it's a
mirror in which you can look at yourself
and you look at the world around you.
Achilles or diaas are in you and you are
in them and by observing them
objectively you can better understand
yourself.
The imagination is enlarged by sympathy
with pains and passions so mighty that
they extend in their conception the
capacity of that by which they are
conceived. The good affections are
strengthened by pity, indation, terror
and sorrow and exact calm is prolonged
from the safety of this high exercise of
them into the tumult of familiar life.
Okay. So the idea of Greek tragedy is um
[clears throat]
epiphany
and cartharsis.
So if you look at uh Greek tragedy
there's a very common pattern. Okay. So
there's a tragic character and he's
undone by hubris.
Okay, that's a great tragic flaw, his
hubris. He's arrogant. Achilles has
hubris. He thinks he's better than
everyone else. Every man has hubris.
He's better than everyone else. Okay,
but will die because of hubris. Hector
will die because of hubris. So it's
hubris that is the great uh killer of
people. Okay? No matter how great you
are, you will suffer from hubris. The
greater you are, the more you you'll
suffer from hubris, which can only lead
to tragedy. And you're observing this
and you recognize that, oh, it's hubris
that leads to tragedy and therefore it
will make you a much more humble person.
Okay, this is what we call epiphany.
But regardless
of your epiphany, you're still going to
face tragedy.
Okay, the person is still going to fall.
So Hector, no matter how great he is,
he's still going to die. Petroas, no
matter how innocent he is, he's still
going to die. Okay? And this will lead
and so what happens is you feel
a connection with that person, you cry.
And this leads to karthis. Okay?
Ctharsis is basically purge.
Whatever feelings that you have, you
cry. You purge your feelings. You you
purge your hubris. You purge your
hatred. Okay? And this will make you a
whole person. But when you commit
karthis, what happens is that you now
connect with the character itself. So
the character now lives in you and you
live in the character.
Okay? And that will make you a much
better person. Does it make sense guys?
All right. Even crime is disarmed of
habits horror and all its contagion by
being represented as a fatal consequence
of the unfathomable agency of nature
does diversity of its wolfliness. Men
can no longer cherish in it as a
creation of their choice. In a drama of
the highest order, there is little food
for sensor or hatred. It teaches rather
than self-nowledge and of self-respect.
Neither the eye nor the mind can see
itself unless reflected upon that which
it resembles. The drama so long as it
continues to express poetry is as a
prismatic and manysided mirror which
collects the brightness rays of human
nature and divides and reproduces them
from the simplicity of these elementary
forms and touches them with majesty and
beauty and multiplies all that it
reflects and endows it with the power of
propagating its like wherever it may
fall. Okay, so this is very long but
it's a very simple idea. The idea is
that
when you watch a tragedy, okay, when you
observe a tragedy, [snorts] you're
observing a fundamental truth about
human nature, okay, which is that we're
all going to be tragic. The classic that
classic case is Edypus. Okay, Edypus is
a man who killed his father and married
his mother. And when he discovers the
the truth, he blinds himself and then he
goes into exile.
Okay. And if you actually read the
tragedy by Sopes, he did nothing wrong.
It was it was just fate. It was just an
accident. But unfortunately, that's what
life is about. Okay. So the you are a
great person when you're able to
acknowledge your limitations.
You're able to acknowledge
um fate and destiny, but you struggle
regardless. Okay, that's what irritate.
That's what ud udimon is to recognize
your limitations to recognize the
universe may have a grudge against you
but you struggle on regardless.
Okay. And that story when you watch it
yourself it brings sorrow to you. It
brings pity but it makes you also much
more wise and reflective about the world
that we live in. Okay. And that's
creates wisdom that creates empathy.
This creates morality. Okay. And that's
why Greek drama is so important. Okay.
Now let's look at another another
passage.
Poets are not only subject to the
experiences or spirits of the most
refined organization but they can color
all that they combine with the evidence
and hues of this ether row. Okay. All
right. This is really important idea.
Remember how we said that poets have a
connection to the vine. Right. So they
are absorbing the guys. They are
absorbing the monad. Okay. But at the
same time they're observing the world
around us, the material. Okay? They're
observing human nature. They're
observing nature like life itself. And
what they do is they combine these two
together. Okay? The present with the
eternal, the here with the forever. And
they turn it into words that are able to
express both the material and the
spiritual. The here and the forever, the
present and the eternal. Okay.
A word, a trait in a representation of a
scene or a passion will touch the
internal cord. Okay. Uh diction or
metaphor.
Internal cord. Internal cord is just
your connection to the line. Okay. So
this word because because it's so
beautiful this sentence so beautiful
will reawaken your memory. Okay. This is
a really important idea where we are
always in a process of um reincarnation.
All right. So why are we here in this
world? Because there are things that we
can experience that we cannot experience
in the spiritual. When we're in the
spiritual, we are formless. We have we
don't have any bodies. Therefore, we can
have se we cannot have sex. We can't
have pain. We can't love. Okay? But in
this world, we can. But what's important
to understand is that we when we
reincarnate into this world, our
memories of our former selves and of the
spiritual world are lost to us.
Otherwise, we can't actually live the
life that that that we live. Okay? But
poetry because it connects both to the
vine and the present. Certain words will
spark your soul and your soul is the
forever memory of all your lives and
your connection to the spiritual. Okay,
that's what poetry does. Poetry is a
gateway into your soul.
and reanaminate. Okay. In those who have
ever experienced these emotions, the
sleeping, the cold, the buried image of
the past. All right?
So, you have all these past lives in you
that you don't remember. But a certain
word, a certain poem will reignite,
reanimate all these past lives in you.
And they will sum up and says, "Hey, we
remember." Okay? And this will elevate
you.
poetry does makes immortal all that is
best and most beautiful in the world. It
arrests the vanishing operations which
haunt the interaluminations of life and
veiling them or in language or in form
sends them forth among mankind bearing
sweet news of kindred joy to those with
whom the sisters abide abide because
there is no more portal of expression
from the caverns of the spirit which
they inhabit into the universe of
things. Poetry redeems from decay the
visitations of the divinity in man and
man. Okay, there's God in us. And poetry
reminds us there is God in us. There's
God everywhere. And poetry reminds us
there's God everywhere. Poetry lets us
see the divine everywhere. Okay, we're
not able to see this because of how our
minds work. Because we're only see able
to see through time and space. But
poetry is helps us go beyond time and
space and connect immediately to the
eternal.
Okay? to the divine, to the spiritual.
[snorts]
[clears throat]
All things exist as they are perceived.
Okay, so again the idea of K where where
we can only see things through time and
space. Okay, these are things we we we
can see. But you know what? There are
things that we can feel that we can't
see. It's the feelings that matter at
least in relation to the recipient. The
mind is it own place and of itself can
make a heaven of hell, a hell of heaven.
Okay? But what this tells us is that if
we learn how to control our minds, we
can control reality itself.
Okay? But poetry defeats a curse which
binds us to be subjected to the asin of
surrounding impressions. Okay? Do you
understand this idea? The idea is poetry
activates our imagination.
Before we were in a prison of our own
making. Before we only could only see
what we could see. But the poetry gives
us a higher sight. It allows us to see
the things beyond just time and space.
The eternal, the past, the future.
And wherever it spreads its own figure
curtain or withdraws life's dark veil
from before the scene of things, it
equally creates for us a being within
our being. Okay.
All right. So each time we use our
imagination, we create our new reality
for ourselves. It makes us the
inhabitants of a world to which the
familiar world is a chaos. It reproduces
a common universe of which we are
portions and recipients and it purchases
from our insight inward insight. The
film of familiar with which obscures
from us the wonder of our being. It
compels us to feel that which we
perceive and to imagine that which we
know. It creates a new the universe
after it has been annalated in our minds
by the recreation or impressions blunted
by reiteration. It justifies the bold
and true words of tassel. None but God
and the poet deserve the name of
creator. The poet is the creator of our
world because the poet has the
imagination to see things beyond time
and space, beyond this reality. And the
poet then distills these emotions into
words that help us ourselves
connect to the divine. Okay? Poetry is a
portal to the divine.
This is this is clear, right guys? All
right. So we'll conclude the most
unfilling hero, companion and follower
of the awakening of a great people to
work a beneficial change in opinion or
institution is poetry. Poetry is the
basis of all civilization.
Okay. It is from poetry that everything
must come from.
At such periods there's an accumulation
of the power of communi communicating
and receiving intent and passion
conceptions respecting man and nature.
The person whom this power resides may
often as we far as regards many portions
of their nature have little apparent
correspondence with that spirit of good
of which they are the ministers. But
even while they deny and objure, they
are yet compelled to serve that power
which is seated on the throne of their
own soul. Okay? So poets don't actually
know their profits. Poets don't know
they're connected to the monad or the
divine. They just do what they do
because they have no choice. Okay?
There's a fire burning in you. You have
to let it out otherwise you you can't
sleep. You can't eat. Okay. Poets are
prophets who must speak the truth
otherwise they will just suffocate.
Okay. They'll just drown in their own
misery.
It is impossible to read the comp
compositions most celebrate writers of
the present day while being startled
with the electric light which burns
within their words. Okay. Poets are the
flame itself. Poets are not human. They
are the messengers of the divine flame.
Okay, they just burn. And when you read
their words, you can see the flame in
them. Okay, so even though Homer, we
don't even know who this guy is. We have
we don't know, we don't have his
picture, but you can see when we read
him, he's alive still. Okay, his words
still burn.
They measure the circum circumference
and sound the depths of human nature
with a comprehensive and arpetuating
spirit. And they are themselves perhaps
the most sincerely astonished at its
manifestations. Okay? It's all
inspiration. When Homer is speaking, he
doesn't know what he's speaking. He
doesn't. Are you telling me like this
guy, he's able to understand? Oh, this
is what Odysius is doing. Odysius is
trying to create a reality and he's
using imagery. He's using diction. No,
no, he doesn't understand anything. He's
just blah blah blah blah blah. Okay,
he's a divine fire.
He's a chat. He's just channeling God.
Okay, he's just a portal for God to
speak with the universe with with us.
Poets are the hopens of an unprehed
inspiration. Okay. The mirrors of the
gigantic shadows which future cast upon
the present. There are prophets because
of future speaking to us today. Okay?
Right? God is past, future, pre present.
And so when God speaks,
he's also speaking to the future.
The words which express what they
understand not. The trumpets which sing
to battle and feel not what they
inspire. The influence which is move
not, but moves. Poets are the
legislators of the world. Okay?
Poets are prophets and their words
create our reality. Every everything
that we know, everything that we do,
it's because of language of the language
that the poets create. Okay? Doesn't
make sense, guys. That's how Homer
created civilization because God willed
it that Homer speak truth and willed
that this truth will spread across the
world through his poetry. Okay? It's all
by design. Does it make sense?
All right. Any questions?
Okay. All right. So, I'll see you guys
next class. Okay.